[Musique]
dans dix minutes c'est la fin d'épreuve
et n'oublierai frontières soient
présentés sur vos postes de travail
plus que dix minutes après quatre heures
de réalisation le stress est donc
palpable pour tout le monde dans cette
salle un concours de croquembouche trois
finalistes
lauriane edwin et nathanaël trois jeunes
tout juste diplômé en pâtisserie le
travail demandé par ce jury
une pièce montée à base de chou au moins
je suis agréablement surpris en fait du
niveau pour des candidats aussi jeune
puisque on est quand même sur un
concours de jeunes et il ya du très beau
travail pendant toute l'épreuve
on va juger leur travail leur façon de
s'organiser
on va également jugé la dégustation
puisque mon devoir nous proposer des
sugar ni que l'on va devoir déguster
puisque ce qui est toujours important en
pâtisserie alors le visuel évidemment
mais le bourg est très très très
important la pâtisserie ou l'art de la
patience la maîtrise de soi rigueur
créativité et beaucoup d'amour pour le
métier pas des morceaux sont cassées et
de d'arranger les choses sans que la
cassure se voit ça va pas être évident
mais ce qui est de se dépêcher et de
réparer la casse
ça fait partie du jeu et c'est une
finale et un concours ouvert au public
une expérience à vivre
j'ai fait une impression d'espacé
voilà donc avec des couleurs un petit
peu qu'on ne voit pas tout de son
apathie ski mais qui en soi peuvent rire
peuvent être glissantes
un peu stressé quand même mais voilà
faut garder la tête froide et ses 2,2
financés pièces en temps et en heure oui
pour travailler des lampes à sucre
ses cheveux ventilateur entre autres et
c'est edwin michaud les 23 ans qui
remporte ce concours de croquembouche
son thème à 26 milieu dans l'espace des
candidats qui ont travaillé chacun avec
un committee ray au sort trois jeunes du
lycée de bellefontaine